first let me start by saying how much I
absolutely loved this movie I'm sure
it's a love fest with every single
person coming into you might be somebody
yet we're in who knows right yeah we
didn't make it I mean I would argue
you're both very integral to the yes but
it's not our movie it's Ryan's movie
yeah he wrote it he constructed it he
cast it mmm he yeah you know toned it
and then he edited scored created it and
presented the love needs to go history
so to him basically well I'm gonna
believe me I'm gonna praise him we're on
the same page I have to I want to start
with a fun question if you don't mind
and I'm very curious and women the fun
no it's actually a combo and someone on
Twitter put this out there
oh no Twitter yes do you think James
Bond can kill Michael mothers he doesn't
die so I don't know why simple you know
he could try I mean I stick him in a
leadbox and throw him into dump it under
Bob the ocean but that's no watch it but
um I absolutely for this movie this
scripts like this don't come along that
often yeah virtually ever exactly so I'm
curious when you're reading it for the
first time were you able to put it
together on your own or was it only when
you finally got to the very end call the
police yeah yeah
I you know I didn't read it like that I
did it's just I kind of was like yeah I
know what it is I know what this is I
read it and I just enjoyed the language
it was literally I read it and I read
each scene and it was just like it was
so I keep my using the rest it was just
delicious it was just and it didn't
matter to me it was a it was that was
sort of secondary to what it was it was
the writing was so good and it was so
interesting so fun they were belly
laughs there were all of these things
and the kind of whole murder mystery of
it is not my business really it's kind
of in a way even though I play the
detective it's it's it's four it was for
Ryan to Manny
and he does it beautifully and when I
saw the finished movie I knew I could I
can I know what happened but I I was
surprised by how much he kind of even
that thing which were isn't it there's a
scene where the way were you waking up
they're waking up to Jaime wakes up like
three times and [ __ ] and she saw this
shot these scenes and it's it's really
integral to the storytelling and I
watched and I went oh my god that's so
beautiful and that's what that's Ryan
it's fun that you're beautiful acting
but it's also right right you know it's
all it's incredibly intricate super
funny and by the way there if you look
back at Ryan's work it's not like he's a
comedy writer mmm I mean I you wouldn't
like James Cameron wrote True Lies if
you looked back at James and James
Cameron's work you would not have called
him a comedy writer and yet True Lies
was legit funny on the page legit funny
this is legit funny and very intricate
and super fun and at this time of year
at this time in our country at this time
just in the world to have a really
satisfying meal of a movie and leave as
you said not knowing who did it and then
going like this and what an amazing ride
you got to go on I mean it's just super
fun I already have to go I really wanted
to ask about the doughnut hole no no no
but Ryan said Ryan said it was a tough
that he wasn't working and that you said
give him like let me work on it right
you know in the doughnut hole speech
yeah the doughnut hole speech which is
amazing yeah yes that by the way that
speech will be done by acting students
for the rest of time god bless them no
seriously people will come in and go hi
I'm doing the scene from knives out
Daniel Craig's character scene and then
they will do the doughnut hole speech